our 902 100 best friends face off what
happens when we interview each other
what has been the highlight of being
back with the gang after 30 years we all
been posting on social and having so
much fun together while we were shooting
but what was it really like that gang it
was we all say surreal but it was like
summer camp because we were all in
Vancouver together which in hindsight I
think was a really great idea because it
took us out of our element and we were
like roommates and the same apartment
building a lot of us and um it was on
one end like remember the first scene I
was like oh my gosh I saw everyone's
face and I was like I can't act I forgot
how to act in front these people and
then I panicked along and panicky I was
like I just forgot how to act
I'm like where's my this voice ever and
then we did in all of a sudden we were
like oh that person right I remember you
and it was you said it best it was like
riding a bike and then we realized you
can go home again mm-hmm good answer
Thanks hey I got one for you okay I
think you might ask me wait no okay now
be honest uh uh when we first started
working on this idea how confident were
you that that we would actually pull
this off like you knew it was something
fresh and different we wanted to do that
but did you think that people would
embrace it as much as they are embracing
it you want me to be honest yeah are you
sure
totes okay I was not sure at all Oh God
people would embrace this concept this
whole sort of meta version of doing a
reboot and I was nervous because it had
never been done before I mean playing
actors playing themselves in roles has
been done by in the movies by different
shows and I know a lot of our
inspiration came from like Larry David
and and the fun of that watching I just
have fun when I watch shows like not so
developing it I was really nervous that
people would be confused that they would
just want to see the characters
but I remember you encouraged me all
along whenever I would have a panic
attack and be like this is not gonna
work they're not gonna like it he would
say yes they are it's gonna be fine and
then you'd have a panic attack and
you're fine
but um I was definitely worried from
from the beginning I I felt like I was
holding my breath for two years because
it was like kind of walking into the
unknown for two years yeah but we
originally thought it would be a half
hour we did really knows we thought it
would be a half hour comedy like Curb
Your Enthusiasm or Larry David but what
a cool idea to take it we were so
nervous to go okay let's make it an hour
but it works somehow works and people
are into it which it's the best thing I
think for me the most rewarding part is
hearing like the critics saying good
things about it and sort of creating
that energy around it which feels really
good I concur how much did you tap into
your dad's creative mind and all of all
of the things that he taught you working
on this a lot I mean obviously we it was
handed hand we worked on this from day
one together I know but your dad is a is
the most famous producer of television
there ever was like you think there's
one in Eugene like there was like you
said moments when when we were like no
we can't do this it's not gonna work
sound work
and my dad was such a fighter like he if
when he had an idea he would not take no
for an answer
like that was it he like stuck to his
vision and you know as we know in life
you know when there's different cooks in
the kitchen things get changed and I
think that's the one thing he taught me
to do is believe in what you create and
don't let that vision go and I feel like
during the process we had like we had
two angels like looking down like I'm
telling us like go ahead and my dad and
Luke were both wanting us to go ahead
with our vision and stick to it so true
what was it like kissing Jason all over
yes give me that God rose
sorry I was having a fangirl moment like
but it's someone you kissed on screen 30
years ago like 25 years ago like this
isn't it bizarre to go back and play a
love scene with someone and how is it
different do you feel like their
characters dynamic then as opposed to
now like obviously it was Brandon and
Kelly Jason and Jenny and please still
HemisFair it's impossible to compare the
two experiences because like you said
one was Brandon and Kelly ones Jason and
Jen but chemistry-wise chemistry-wise
it's you know Jason and I work really
well together
and we're both just in it to win it and
let's get this and let's go home you
know kind of a thing so there's not a
lot of drama or any extra stuff going on
and kissing him was just like old times
like it's the same like it felt exactly
the same like riding a bike it's like
riding a bike
Jennie Garth says kissing Jason
Priestley is like riding a bike
oh it makes you sweaty wait but you had
to kiss Bryan what was that like I was
nervous for a moment I was like it would
have been less nervous it was someone
new I think but it's someone I was like
oh my gosh like what if he what if I'm
not explicitly out what if he's like who
this poor thing's gone downhill like yes
oh so this is a question fans are
wondering
they just got to see a brief peek at
Kelly what is Kelly doing now like is
she the owner of the Peach Pit cuz
that's what they saw in Tori's dream
right in toys dream she was running and
owning the Peach Pit with Brandon um
what is Kelly Taylor doing I think that
she's a savvy businesswoman
Owens her own business whatever it is
whether it's the Peach Pit I'm not sure
she's back at the Peach Pit but not as
an owner so that ought to be fun yeah so
we see Kelly again in Episode two and
she's not in the peach pit she's not
owning the peach pit with Brandon she's
walking the halls of Beverly Hills High
and just West Beverly you're laughing if
I named it wrong
and she's tapping into her fears and
probably insecurities about going on
board with a reboot and going back into
that kind of world but I don't know what
she would really be doing like she I
don't know she have cats or dogs hmm
maybe like she's a cat person really
yeah um no one rocks a bang like you do
oh my god has Kelly Taylor and I got to
tell you watching because we do dream /
nightmare sequences through the whole
show not each week we open on that and
seeing you back in your bang as Kelly
Taylor like I was like oh my gosh it was
like looking at the 17 year old version
of you if you say so what did you feel
like watching all the other actors get
back into their 90210 characters for the
dream sequences it was so fun in that
makeup trailer on those dream or
nightmare sequence because what we would
I would just look over and I would see
Brandon like it was just a trip we would
put his hair up and be in the peach
peach shirt and you with the dirt you
had um you had your hair over with dark
roots and we tried to do nineties makeup
it was so fun it was like we were
dressing up for Halloween we were
dressing up as our characters was fun it
was okay you okay okay
ah fans of 90210 where were and are
pretty diehard what memory do you have
of being with me in the early days when
the fans were just swarming us do you
have any memories of that or just like
on your own do you remember the frenzy
that was the original I feel like when
we used to go shopping it like if we'd
be on location we would go shopping a
lot like in our like sneak out yeah
sneak out in our bathrobes the thing
isn't the bodyguards would come and we'd
be like oh where are we filming cuz we
didn't get out much so in between like
any location we would film if there were
stores we were super excited some like
like real life people would go in and
like buy stuff guys remember
the fans were like all around it's weird
they see one of us it's like something
but when they see more than one of the
great together and it's real it blows
their minds yeah still to this day so
there were a ton of flashbacks for the
fashion on BH 90210
can you tell us a little bit about how
that came to be and how you were very
intercooling that dress you wore in the
peach pit so we we were on a crazy time
schedule as you know and pretty much
writing the episodes as we were filming
them so they the show evolved as we all
evolved together and I feel like we have
a dream slash or a nightmare sequence in
every single episode and it's from a
different characters perspective and it
opens the show so the fans get to see
all the original characters the first
one that we weren't quite sure the
direction we were gonna take the rest in
so I feel like we were trying to do a
modern nod at 90s mm-hmm that's why like
gap Gabrielle has her short hair in it
and she'll go back to long Andreea hair
later we felt like your outfit was kind
of a modern not at Kelly Taylor like you
used to wear short skirts he had a long
pencil skirt on instead so your pop
colors your blues that you were always
known for as Kelly Donna I found a daisy
dress but it had like it was a peplum
little flirty skirt instead of a bigger
skirt is that what you mean yeah and
just like yeah kind of an updated night
but still like that iconic you're like
oh it's 90s but with a little twist I
know I could always count on you to
bring back something that we wore from
the original because I have no memory of
any of it until you're like here look at
the picture look what you're wearing
we're gonna do that but that was really
a fun component of it I think was
getting to go down memory lane and then
reprise those looks in a modern day
definitely we just did that again with
the Teen Choice Awards they did when you
had a great idea
a modern nod at the sunflower and iconic
fashion fave yeah it's fun to tweak it
and I feel like fashion was like its own
character and I notice who went oh
mm the wardrobe so I think we definitely
I mean Mandy line our Emmys amazing
costume designer on pH notes or no did
such a great job of making sure each
character had such a specific fashion
sense
it was very emotional like all the
outfits that went with each character
and complex and I think the fans are
really gonna find that as intriguing as
everything else on the show yeah it's
definitely fun to watch the Wardrobe so
what is the one thing that might
surprise fans about our friendship we
we've known each other for a long time
as you said and we actually even live
together in Vancouver what was it like
being my roommate in a two-bedroom
apartment it was so fun it was so fun
remember it was so fun it was so fun so
have you guys seen The Odd Couple that's
us uh and wait which I'm you're whoever
the messy one is she's feeling like he's
feel she's a total neat freak
which is a great thing like oh my gosh I
mean is it neat freak is that really the
title that you want but I think some
people call it okay she's tidy clean
tidy clean she's I like things in or
order in their plate it like I don't
know I just can't live with craziness
around me or anything because it's crazy
enough in here like I need things to be
common and in everything I remember at
first I used to get nervous because you
would just be cleaning everything and
moving and I'd come we'd come home from
work so tired after like a 17-hour day
and be like 3:00 in the morning and
you'd be like cleaning and I'd be like
okay sure how and then I started to
realize that like it's not about that
it's just like you have to let you do it
mm-hmm
so I had to stop feeling guilty and be
like okay can you tell my husband my
house is never left so Johnny Garth but
you are very sweet I will say because
you were so worried about my cleanliness
and my issues with that and the
opposites of us that you had a
housekeeping service come in every
single day she's lying to clean up
Thursday so it felt like every day but
we were at a furnished living place
where they offer at one time a week it
comes with the whole thing and then I
saw them there and I was like so worried
that you would have to come home at 3:00
in the morning and feel the need to
clean dishes that I was trying to take
the burden off of you I think it's is
not a need for me it's like I it relaxes
me to do that makes me very nervous when
you do it do it while I'm drinking glass
of wine is that okay that takes the edge
off mmm I'm so tired let me sit on this
couch somebody take my Spanx off and I'm
wine and you're just like I'm sorry I
really put you through it but you did a
good job of keeping your mess in your
room mostly I'm shutting the door thanks
mom great okay that makes me feel better
but it's interesting because there's a
lot of things that people say like
what's the one thing you haven't done
together like we've done a lot together
in 30 years that was the one thing we
had never done together was live
together on it in real life we've had
the beach apartment we lived together
for years in 90210 there originally but
never in real life mm-hmm I think the
prop guys made it neat for you but I
didn't know then that I was that messy
and now we all know you're not that
messy you just were relaxing in vh9 o2i
when they would show Tori I'd be like no
just throw stuff around no set design
you had to go in and like mess version
of me mm-hmm
I think we should do a road trip like a
go in an RV somewhere together I would
love to do that with the dogs with the
dogs oh so our dogs
little known fact sisters not much
people don't know
so our dogs became best friends too
which
I think is really cute we should hit the
road we're getting ready to do a tour we
are uh what's that gonna be like any
ideas I have so many ideas right so
we're we're taking it on the road
some people say we're good together so
we're hitting the road see what happens
I think the funnier part of that it
would be the traveling part to be honest
and the dogs and the kids of it all and
really want to be an RV with you I
really do going anywhere together is
like a road show it really is it's like
a science project but in a fun way like
his stuff just happens yeah but it's
good um but this way we get to be with
friends girlfriends bring her
girlfriends boyfriends bring her
boyfriend
yeah it's gonna be like a girls night
out we're gonna try to make it really
fun for girls and guys to come and just
hang with us for the night talk like
this liked I feel with them and do you
never a game where the conversations
gonna go and she's a big game player
yeah and super competitive it gets
released it gets really scary Thanks
yeah I feel like I feel like we really
played against each other in something I
like a game game I don't think we've
ever done that I don't think so but I
think you would your you would get
competitive again I mean I would bring
it out of you well I'd have to gauge
your reaction and I might have to let
you win mmm wait no I let you win
MasterChef I didn't let you win but you
won master chef chef master chef yeah
and you wouldn't even enjoy winning it
cuz afterwards I was like is she mad she
mad I was so she was so mad just cuz
she's super competitive and I was like
oh is this okay and there was I gonna
enjoy it but yeah I was really hurt I
was very happy for Stella right so that
was the one saving grace it was a
mother-daughter so you were okay with
that I mean what games are we gonna play
on the road though with people I don't
know we have to think of that to think
of some good ideas anyway duck duck
goose heads up seven up no never played
that one we put your head down in class
and they come and they hit your thumb
and then you were it but people do a
really Hardy way
no no hangman I like hangman
we have heard rumor that season two
could depend on how the ratings do and
it was just announced the BH 902 a no
posted the highest rated summer series
debut in more than two years I think
we're getting a season two if yes I
think well I I don't know honestly if
won't be getting a season two I don't
know if everybody's gonna be able to be
on board with their schedules I mean
that we got a season one was a miracle
and no small feat so if we can stay
together and do it again I think we
would have even more fun I mean I think
there can't be a coincidence that we're
all back in each other's lives so
hardcore I think at this point we can
all agree to disagree that we're like we
do that that we're stuck with each other
all of us stuck is the blade worth 30
years later here we are doing it again
and yeah it would it would be great and
we have so many stories to tell
oh my gosh cuz season 2 would be the
reboot so you would see the actual show
within the show all the time some of the
really crazy delve into those characters
hardcore and where they are now this
would be fun
you